-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, this week, I sent out
the hashtag #MyRoommateIsWeird.
[ Laughter ]
I asked you to tweet out
something funny, weird,
or embarrassing
about your roommate.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I thought I could share
some of my favorite
#MyRoommateIsWeird tweets.
There are some weird roommates
out there.
This first one is
from @asgeirson. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
-Ah. Gravy.
-This one is from @fallonholic.
-Ooh!
-That's my favorite one.
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Just in case."
-Weird. Yeah, bizarre.
This one is from @cafiussjk.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
This next one's
from @itsmellama.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
Who is it?
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Bro."
-Shhhh.
-This one's from @briancrider.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
[ Mimics electricity zapping ]
"Bro!"
-"Let's go to class."
-"Back off, bro."
-"Back off, bro!
Back the eff off."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Mimics electricity zapping ]
-This one's from @simonptopping.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, God.
-That's kind of fun, man.
That's #MyFunRoommate.
-Oh, fun roommate.
-This one's from @choorel.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yabba-dabba-doo.
-Oh, there we go.
[ Laughter ]
This last one is from
@chriscrandell83. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.